salut comment ça va regarder avec qui je
suis aujourd'hui vous la connaissez pas
c'est malika de samsung et malika de
samsung elle est super sympa et surtout
malika de samsun alors c'est pas son nom
de s'abîmer lequel samsung ça pourra
faire un nom un peu composer mais normal
qu'un échec produits samsung au niveau
des tablettes ça va mal qu'a très bien
être je suis au top ce trésor être avec
toi pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas une nouvelle tablette samsung galaxy
tab et suite samsung galaxy tab est sud
plus samsung galaxy tab et suite ultra
et ça c'est un tout nouveau modèle
alors je vous ai posé la question
d'abord comment ça va très bien et toi
tu vois bien fait la même chose deux
fois de suite oui très heureuse d'être
là est très très heureuse aux cd
tous très heureuse aujourd'hui alors on
a trois nouveaux modèles qu'est ce qu'il
raconte cette gamme publisud on a une
nouvelle gamme de tablettes les tabacs
suite à suite plus est ultra nouveauté
cette année donc on a une nouvelle
catégorie sur les tablettes la catégorie
ultra pourquoi c'est ma question est la
plus courue j'en ai conscience mais en
fait quand tu penses aux tablettes
autant d'ultras de réussir sur un
smartphone aime dire ok alors je vais
aller le plus loin possible
là aussi pourquoi pas est ce qu'il ya un
marché à venir chercher ce qu'il y avait
un manque dans la gamme pourquoi le trac
est ce que raconte m l'ultra unissent ou
pas oui ici après je te répondre
j'arrête de couper l'équipe eroglu qui
toujours en train de couper les autres
comme ça la suite fait le jeu d'un micro
qui est absolument dingue en fait 58
très très grand 14 6 pouces c'est fou
14,6 pouces ok alors vas-y raconter nos
histoires est donc la tab est ultra est
partie la gamme des tablettes suit donc
on a l'état baisse suite à celui de plus
qui s'inscrivent dans la continuité des
tables et c'est à cette puce est donc là
on a une nouveauté la tab est ultra
particularité de cette tablette c'est
qu'elle fait 14 6 pouces grand écran
pourquoi pour différentes raisons la
première c'est que effectivement on
constate qu'en termes d'usagés ans se
tend de plus en plus vers des écrans de
plus en plus grands oui donc c'est une
demande qui a été constaté et en plus de
ça samsung aime toujours poussé au
maximum toutes les possibilités qu'on
peut avoir avec un produit et donc le
fait d'avoir un grand écran ça permet de
faire tout ce qu'on peut faire sur des
tables et suite à suit plus mais en
allant encore plus loin parce qu'on est
sur grand écran l'idée c'est quoi en
fait ici c'est de se dire pour toutes
les personnes qui ont pas des besoins de
performance au niveau 2 les ordinateurs
ça vient concurrencer un peu
d'ordinateurs ça vient à prendre la
place parce que je me dis allez je me
faire un petit tableau en ligne je veux
venir taper un courrier souvenirs
regarde une vidéo là dessus je suis
hollywood il veut venir jouer un jeu
tout des choses que je peux faire avec
un pc mais j'ai pas forcément besoin
d'un pc pg de la modularité est ce que
c'est le solide et on fait ça l'idée
c'est de pousser l'utilisation de la
tablette surtout les tous les pans
d'utilisation qu'elle peut apporter et
donc effectivement il ya tous les usages
de bureautique les usages des
divertissements les usages de retouche
photo notamment grâce au sp n et après
effectivement entre un pc une tablette
ce sera plutôt un choix de systèmes
d'exploitation finalement et besoin au
quotidien qui restent du coup à la
discrétion de chaque mets donc là c'est
vraiment poussé au maximum tous qu'une
tablette peut nous offrir grâce à la
tablette ultra serrée qu'elle est ma
grande très honnêtement mais vous n'êtes
pas forcément besoin de l' ultra c'est
pour ça qu'il ya d'autres qui sont elle
est quand même assez grande on la voit
comme ça lorsque assez marrant c'est
qu'on va effectivement quand on a une
petite encoche qui arrive parce qu'on a
deux caméras si je me trompe pas ces
deux caméras de 12 mégapixels ici oui il
s'agira pourquoi pour la visioconférence
d'actes mans on a deux caméras 12
mégapixels une grand-angle
ultra-grand-angle coule donc ça permet
d'avoir des appels vidéo immersifs en
plus de ça on a trois micros avec
réduction de bruit donc encore plus
immersif et le fait d'avoir un grand
écran ça rend la l'expérience encore
plus agréable et en plus de ça on a des
fonctionnalités d'auto freyming ondes
automatique lumineux zoom out en
fonction d'eux des personnes qui sont
dans la pièce et qui qui parle donc ça
devrait me ça permet vraiment de rendre
plus naturel l'expérience donc en fait
cette fonctionnalité l'asservir a
effectivement sur la partie visio qu'on
savait dire que si moi je vais me
déplacer la caméra en tout cas la
personne qui me regarde on a
l'impression que la caméra me suis fait
un focus sur moi surtout quand ton
talent surtout quand je parle d'accord
si je ne parle pas que quelqu'un
derrière moi se met à parler ce que ça
va venir sur lui ou pas oui exactement
d'accord ok c'est génial ok donc on peut
faire de se mettre à 2,3 et puis on
revient sur la personne et les choses à
dire ok très chaud on comprend le
placement de ce produit on comprend tout
le côté productivité alors on l'a
testera ultérieurement comme ça on
arrivera mieux se projeter mieux réussir
à comprendre les différents usages parce
qu'il y en a plusieurs donc là on est
sur de très gros modèles on a ensuite
deux autres tablettes un peu plus petite
la suite et la suite plus est ce que tu
peux nous les nous les montrer je me
permets juste d'ajouter que le s pen est
inclus est riche et
samsung galaxy tab est ultra et donc
c'est le cas aussi sur la galaxy tab est
suite à celui de plus voilà j'aime on
espère qu'il fournira le coupé ultra
presse il est alors j'ai vu dans la
présentation que sur le suit on aura une
précision moindre que sur le suit plus
et laissent une ultra au niveau du
respect donc les s pen entre la
génération tabac suite et la génération
tab à 7 ont été améliorés les
respectables chutes sont extrêmement
précis on pourra les tester mais il ya
une différence entre le respect dû aux
ut dièse plus donc les espèces des
tabacs suite sont très précis l'espagne
est en baisse suite plus est habituel
tracé encore plus précis d'accord est en
fait celui qu'on a sur l'interdît suit
celui qu'on avait sur les générations
précédentes ou pas non il a aussi été
améliorée il a été amélioré mais c'est
de l'autre au dos et ça c'est un peu ce
sens
la tablette suit plus et la table est
utile sera donc le s pen qui inclut est
deux fois plus précis que le smn qui
était inclus dans l'état baisse est plus
d'accord donc en fait on se dit quoi on
se dit qu'avec un incident plus est un
site ultra on s'adresse aux personnes
qui ont vraiment des gros besoins en
termes de dessins de précision qui
veulent vraiment avoir une sensation
d'écriture le plus naturel possible la
sensation d'écriture ont là que ce soit
sur la table au dessus de la table la
suite plu soit avait su le tram
excellent pour les personnes qui sont
extrêmement sensibles à ça au
qu'effectivement c'est diriger plutôt
vers taba sud plus aux tab est ultra on
a compris merci malika alors s'il
faisait montre moi s'il te plaît parce
que ce sont plutôt cool donc j'ai l'âge
et un coloris argent ya six ans quand
série sur wii on n'a pas montré
l'arrière aussi way tellement de choses
à voir et donc ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que donc on a la bande
magnétique qui permet d'avoir en termes
de design le s pen qui s'intègrent
parfaitement ok donc là je vais poser
sur le côté on est d'accord oui je
voulais poser derrière rossi et cinq
semaines connectés donc il se recharge
sa
troupe ce hockey ça tombe pas c'est
plutôt bien ok très bien donc ça c'est
la suite life feat on se pousse on se
pousse hockey est là il suffit de plus à
l'est un point le plus grande mais on
reste dans la même idée sauf qu'on en
espagne qui va être un peu plus précis
que celui de la suite 2,4 pouces 12
points 4 sur la suite plus on a un écran
super amoled ok donc là donc ça c'est du
hameau superbright donc le prix moyen
sur une technopole est donc ces deux
super amoled sur l'autre c'est quoi
c'est dû à la continuité de thabet cet
état cette puce est ici on est sur du
super amoled également
grenade eu 120 hertz partout ok ça
fonctionne en termes de performances on
a quoi on al sadr agon 8 jonone
sur les trois modèles sont conservés sur
les trois modèles savoir ce qu'elle met
aujourd'hui en termes de performance sur
ce sur cette tablette en tout cas en
terme de deux rames il ya une différence
ou pas oui combinaison de ram sont
différentes on est sur du 8 gigas de ram
sur les tables suite tu avais su de plus
sur les tables est ultra en fonction de
la capacité de stockage on a une rame
différentes pour 128 giga on a 8 gigas
de ram pour 256 giga en a 12 giga de ram
et 512 jk on a 16 du cadre a annoncé on
peut vraiment ressentir le besoin de
performance qu'on a qui est corrélé au
stockage exactement et on a le port
micro sd pour ajouter sur les 300 son
mémoire externe jusqu'à
je la trouve super je veux la garder
comme ça très bien ce qu'il faut qu'on
soit authentique ok on est dans la
vérité on est dans l'instant excusez moi
d'avoir mené
la doua fuissé naturel cela m'a plu
c'est la vie très bien ça c'est bien moi
ça me plaît c'est ok donc on voit qu'on
peut faire tout ça on a également des
caméras donc là j'ai double capteur est
ce que j'ai double capteur aussi sur les
services associés partout c'est la même
chose en photo sur tous les modèles oui
c'est du 13 mégapixels et du méga pixels
d'accord ok par ici on n'est pas dans
l'idée d'aller chercher des plus belles
photos sur puce pour unir scanner un
document oui pour prendre des photos de
qualité extraordinaire de
plus que moyen extraordinaire regardez
pour les as ici ben oui parce que
forcément on en parle et sont sortis
aussi soleil sont annoncés c'est lé
nouveau flagship de l'année 2022 pour
samsung c'est une autre vidéo mais on
n'a pas ok donc on voit qu'ici on a
retiré une armada de tablettes qui
devraient pouvoir correspondre à tout un
chacun je pense que ça va être vraiment
intéressant de me laisser le temps de
les tester de voir effectivement à qui
elles correspondent quels usages
pourquoi savoir quel samsung galaxy tab
s est fait pour vous au final puis il ya
les modèles des années antérieures qui
peuvent aussi être intéressant
j'aimerais qu'on parle un peu de prix
parce que j'imagine qu'elles sont pas
gratuites en termes de prix
gratos je passe à côté ça coûte combien
donc en termes de prix sur l'état baisse
suit brême démarre à 769 euros roule sur
les tables suite flux ou là ont des
marques à 999 euros quasiment 1990
les ventes allaient site ultra on
démarre à 1219 ok 1200 les infos on dit
très clairement ici sur un outil pour la
productivité sur des jo pour les vrais
gros besoins je peux dire promet presse
parce que l'on est quand même beaucoup
dans une hauteur ou des gens qui veulent
se faire plaisir et avoir une expérience
divertissement immersif et après moi ce
que j'aime toujours dire c'est qu'à
autant d' usage de la tablette que d'
utilisateurs de la tablette donc c'est à
vous ouais minutes de soins euros je
comprends ce que tu dis oui mais moi je
me dis que si je me prends une tablette
juste pour un côté divertissement et
parce que j'ai un bel écran et un grand
écran c'est 1200 milles de ce nom c'est
une très jolie tablette attention si
j'ai beaucoup d'argent et je me dis je
m'en fiche mignot 100 euros ça ne va ok
mais on fait attention et il faut des
hommes chargés the te confirme que
l'expérience de divertissement sur les
tablettes suite et sans examen suite
plus est excellente et galons oui
clairement on n'ya pas pensé je suis
effectivement des envies de chacun et
jetant des sites ça donc effectivement
on voit que sur salaire d'une petite
encoche 2 par le fait de se dire que
l'écran viens monter un peu plus haut ce
qui dans l'idée est pas bête qu'est ça
c'est la première fois chez vous ça
c'est rigolo se retrouve avec ça comme
ça il sent les autres on ne l'a pas ok
bon écoute trop chouette est ce que tu
vois d'autres choses à venir ajouté dans
ce produit ou pas du tout une dernière
chose a ajouté oui on a une offre de
lancement à partir du 9 février sur les
galaxy tab et suit donc pour l'achat
d'une galaxy tab à sita sud plus à
partir du 9 février on a un qui bordent
slim qui est offert aux quais et pour
l'achat des galaxy tab est suite ultra
ou d'un book over qui bordent qui au
fait ok la différence c'est que lebouc
over qui borde slim donc gelé ici oui
c'est un bouc over et on a le clavier
mais c'est sans tache pas dessus tu me
connais oui je me sens moins d'un peu
sauvage donc là alors faut imaginer
votre tablette dessus donc ça s'est fait
comme ça c'est le bouc copper study le
nom c'est beaucoup verts qui bordent
film ok donc plus fin donc qui prend le
moins d'espacé notamment parce que il
n'ya pas le match pas donc c'est donc je
me déplace en touchant mon écran et ici
tout absent un petit clavier en fait
exact donc ça c'est un modèle de demos
et un qwerty mais où vous aurez un
azerty parce que ici on est en france et
ouais on est comme ça donc ça c'est cool
ok donc ça c'est pour la suite la suite
plus la suite la suite plus est sur un
modèle ultra lors des six barres qui est
en deux parties là on va lire dans la
broussaille à se positionner sur la
tablette à vous faire un petit chevalet
et en plus vous avez un petit rangement
garder ici pour me remettre d'autres
respecte donc assez coulé il se recharge
et dabo l emplacement est prévu pour et
ça c'est bien et ça c'est
le clavier le petit clavier y vient se
clipser là et là je peux venir naviguer
en fait là j'ai une expérience
d'ordinateurs exactement une expérience
ordinateur
ok on comprend la différence et d'un
coup je te remercie beaucoup malika
c'est plutôt que la russie et qui
bordent on a un bonus reprises jusqu'à
100 euros pour la table et suit donc
jusqu'à 150 euros pour la tv suit plus
et jusqu'à 200 euros pour la tablette
ultra d'accord donc ça veut dire que si
je te ramène par exemple une samsung
galaxy tab est celle de l'année dernière
dubertrand à son prix le prix vous
estimez qu'il ya qu'elle vaut
aujourd'hui plus 100 150 ou 200 euros en
fonction du modèle que j'ai pris et je
suis très content merci beaucoup malika
écoute tu suis content de voir ces
produits je les trouvais intéressant on
se parlera bien évidemment un peu plus
tard de ces produits je sais pas lequel
doit tester nos jours et bien dans
l'ultra puis j'avais en tête sur une
table suite ou une table on verra merci
médicale mercy est très heureux de
t'avoir aujourd'hui 6 puis on reparlera
de tablettes un prochaine fois avec toi
comme ça maintenant qu'on est potes
comme ça beaucoup à la merci bas grand
plaisir merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous aurez
appris des choses sur ces nouvelles tab
de samsung est ce que vous pourriez vous
71 ou par une tablette de samsung ce
soit une suite et suit plus et suite
ultra et si oui laquelle ce important le
savoir vous marrer tout certains
évidemment aux commentaires nous on
retrouve très vite pour continuer bien
évidemment à part les tec a parlé de
samsung sur le fait tout péter herbel ça
se passe devant et bisous à m
[Musique]